so i'm very honored and
very happy to be able to
participate in the celebration of dan's
birthday and
his receipt of the
wolf prize
uh i remember when i came here uh
it was 1970 i was still in my 20s and
after i came here dan was chairman
and he took care of
of me in every way
it's uh
in the settling in and
you know all aspects of
department life and social life
and also uh more important he changed
the direction of my research
because before i came i was working on
something else and then afterwards i
went into this whole area of rigidity
it's uh
it
i was of course in this building at my
office i remember dan's often on fourth
floor uh more or less at the end
and at one time uh first i had office
here on the second floor and then move
up i was told that now the chair has my
office
and then uh dan dub
uh
told me about his work about um
reflection uh subgroups to try to
produce an arithmetic lattice
and
he was uh using a lot of computers in
those days and at one point
he did not quite yet get the discrete
subgroup the almost discrete subgroup
and he wondered what could be done with
it and that's
the point that
i was introduced to his great work
so we were trying to compute
various things volumes turn cars and so
forth one thing that really shocked me
was that
dan was 20 years my senior i think he's
still my 20 years my senior year
but when we're trying to compute things
uh in hyperbolic drama through all these
hyperbolic signs and so forth when you
actually really want to compute things
you have to
do things arithmetically and
uh
he could do it uh at tremendous speed
and i was 20 years his junior as i was
you know
very slowly writing down he could you
know just do like this i was extremely
shocked i mean this guy's is his
intellectual power
uh it's just fantastic so i sort of one
day the timidly asked him how could you
confuse so fast he was very modest he
told me that uh he spent four years
doing this uh during the war
uh he was teaching people how to fly
cannons
and the cannons had such a big range
that the curvature of the earth had to
be taken into account so he was using
spherical uh functions not the
hyperbolic ones but of course the change
of sign even with the change of sign you
could do it without mistake quickly it's
still a tremendous feat
and so this thing i i distinctly
remember i don't know whether i didn't
remember this or not
uh so after that uh you know i studied
his work
and i i saw this uh wonderful treasure
so i went into it and tried to
understand it
and of course
his
contribution only changed my direction
will change the direction i of many many
people i think
and uh since my background is more in
complex geometry so
i have been quite biased so looking at
the
complex uh side of it
especially the killer and complex
geometric side of it
there's another thing
that sort of
accidentally pushed me into this area
it was a casual conversation with
kakutani another colleague here
and one time was a chatting you know
kakutani was talking about youth and
then i asked him
about the pre-war days i mean he was
writing papers in german you know so so
he told me about his work
and then one thing he tried to explain
to me was the relation between
harmonic maps and random walk algorithm
and so forth harmonic functions and
harmonic measures so actually
it has nothing to do with dan's work but
it sort of stayed in my mind so i was
looking at dan's work because he was
looking uh
as
curt sold
man maniphany uh
reproduced
with color pictures of his
uh alcohol dixie at the boundary
so uh
at that point um
i went into it because i tried to use
geometric methods to understand dance
so to me dan's work
is a question of
getting something
much more than
the given topological conditions so
you're given topology condition you want
to conclude from it
much more say like metric conditions
uh like group conditions
so um
the
the starting point
uh in the um
uh
in the work going into algebraic
geometry uh from dan's uh
important uh
foundation
uh is the
question of perfect square
so it actually started already from
elliptic operators
so when you
try to solve an equation let's say
laplacian
equal to f so it's a single equation but
then you could get much more from it
uh
let's say you get the estimate the first
order derivative and so forth even
though it's a single equation but you
could get estimates
of the others uh
something like this just by integration
by parts
so uh so this
situation is a matter of writing this
operator as some of the squares
okay so this thing here of course would
be of course it's given already a sum of
squares
okay
so if you look at it from the point of
view of symbols
so it would be a
quadratic polynomial
and it's quadratic polynomial the
written is sum of squares plus something
so it's the usual way of solving
quadratic equations
so
i mean i i never could get this formula
right but
it's something like this i think
plus 4ac minus
b squared
or 8 something
so
what happens is that
for this kind of situation
of course it's already given but in
general when you have a second order
differential operator and you write down
in symbols you could always apply the
completion of squares to it
and of course the component squares
would give information only after you
integrate by parts so when you regard
the
operator as
uh
as an operator on the hilbert space so
to speak when you take uh it's a
positive definite and so forth in that
sense okay
so
when you look at
dan's work of using
properties or hyperbolic space actually
in geometry it is the question of
curvature
so you start out with curvature
and then from curvature you want to say
that given any topological condition
uh
of course
up to homotopy
then you could actually
find
a great deal of information a great deal
of properties
and the main thing is the
completion of squares a perfect square
so
the first
thing that could be done
from that point of view
is a
map
let's say you start out with a map from
m
let's say it's a compact
tailor manifold
into another manifold
and
if you look at the dan's situation
it would be in the case of let's say
a compact quotient
of
an irreducible
bounded symmetric domain
because you have to rule out the case of
complex dimension one so if of complex
dimension
at least two so that was the starting
point
and um there
one wants to
get this elliptic operator in to
complete the square
so if you are given
a homotopy class
so
inside this homotopic class you try to
minimize something
and
what is being minimized is the
energy
so
when you minimize the energy actually
this is the generalization of the
situation of geodesics
so when you look at geodesics uh close
your desks
uh then you are looking at the s1
inside
n for example okay
uh and then of course geodesic you could
minimize the length
or you can minimize the energy actually
it doesn't really matter that much so if
you have f here you could minimize f
let's say to alpha
alpha is
bigger than one half they will give you
the same result if you look at the arc
length
when you do the computation
so
in this case
when you try to
minimize it you take the steepest
descent
so you take the euler ground equation
okay
and get the gradient and you deform
to descend
and then um
you get uh
the answer of course in order to get the
answer you have to get some condition
uh if you get the descent
uh the descent would be like uh
like df dt
sort of like minus laplacian
yeah
laplacian
of
of df
yeah
this is from the euler ground equation
of integrate by particle okay
so there
you will get the heat equation
to do it
and then in order to make sure that the
limit is achieved
you need some as scholarly a seller
argument
let's call it
a zero argument
and there's probably a zero argument
need some estimates
and the estimate that is needed
actually would be something like this
if you take the energy which is this one
here
okay
uh then
you would when you write it down if the
curvature
the sectional curvature of n
is non-positive you would get less than
or equal to
just a constant times the energy
okay and then uh there
you could
use the maximum principle for the heat
operator
okay
and to make sure that this thing
responds in subnorm if you proceed and
then the scalar cell theorem works okay
so um
in the case of uh the curve
uh you have uh
uh the usual jacobi field a second
variation
of the arc length
and the generalization the high
dimensional case
is the same it was done by using samsung
of course it has nothing to do with
complex structure as long as it's
semi-positive this thing whole so once
you get it
uh you would get a harmonic map
so the harmonic map actually is
the generalization of the geodesic in a
high dimensional case
and so you take the harmonic map
equal to zero okay when you take
harmonic you have to interpret in terms
of the connections here and here
so it starts out with the something
topological
and then
you want to derive some more properties
from it so we appeal to this idea of the
elliptic operator and completion square
to try to handle it as sort of classical
and then you get to
the harmonic one and then from a
harmonic one
you want to show that you get something
more than that by integration by parts
essentially so you want to say that
either this one is equal to 0
or d bar f equal to 0.
so
how is this done
this actually is the same as
codar's vanishing theorem
the same as the boxner's uh technique
so for coda's vanishing theorem
there are two forms of it
one is
x the line bundle
plus k x equal to zero for all p bigger
than equal to 1
when this one is positive
or
you have this one equal to 0
for all p less than the dimension
of x
for
if l
is negative
of course one is actually a dual of the
other okay
and the way the dual works
is that
you actually have
in this case in either case let's say
the case p equal to one okay
and it is because of this condition
that
this is needed
that actually is the reason why this is
needed
so
what happens is that you pull back
so you have a harmonic map let's say x
and y for example
you can pull back the tangent bundle
okay by f
and um
then take the d bar of that so d bar
puts it pulls it back
so this is d bar valued
zero one four
on x which is d bar of f
you pull it back
and then
you want to apply this one here
of squares
and if the curvature condition is
correct that means this is less than
zero
uh then uh it forces this one to be zero
so it'll be holomorphia already so the
the only question is to interpret the
notion of curvature
so the curvature here
is a bit more complicated
because the curvature comes from this
guy here
and this guy has to be pulled back
first
and the pullback depends on f
so when you compile it
you actually get um
a condition
involving um
r
of sort of d f
d by f d f
d by f
so the curvature looks like um
this thing wedge this thing which and
then it's symmetric here that's what the
curvature is yeah so this uh there's a
wedge being involved okay so when you
pull back of course the df is
involved but since you have taken a d
bar already here so the extra one will
be here
so when you take something like this
and you say that this is less than or
equal to 0
then this is now
known as the complexified
curvature
a complexified section of curvature less
than equal to zero
because when you look at the curvature r
usually is real
x y let's say x y x y or something
or y x doesn't matter okay so
when you
allow complex values so x for example is
equal to s i t
and then y equal to u
iv then it becomes the curvature
operator condition and this coverage
operating condition
uh it turns out to be the natural one
for the vanishing so the important thing
for this kind of situation is that
um if you take compare quotient you do
so compare symmetric manifold
and if the rank
of this is sufficiently large
for example that's always the case uh if
uh
for example if this is a homotopic
equifax then it's sufficiently large
okay so when it's sufficient the reason
why it needs sufficiently large is that
you have
this term to help you
either force this thing to be zero or
this thing to be zero
but
in the case of uh
binary symmetric domains you may have
some threat direction so you have to
have enough
directions uh that is negative enough to
force this to happen okay so this was
actually the first step
of using dan's idea
of
getting
this strong agility
so
at one point
i was dreaming that
maybe you could get something
concerning the horse conjecture with
this
okay
so
for the horse conjecture
you start with x
and you take a class inside
a pp type
and then of course you want to say that
it's represented by something uh
holomorphic okay of course let's say
over q or whatever it doesn't matter
that's not the main point so this
you type the type pp okay
then one
idea is to minimize the volume
you do it okay you minimize the volume
the trouble is that nobody knows how to
use the conditional pv type
and also when you minimize the volume
uh regularity is a big problem
and when you look at
the situation
like the geodesic
you can minimize the length or you can
minimize the energy so minimize the
energy actually give you regularity more
easily
the
the price you have to pay
is that you need a model for it
if you just minimize the volume inside
then you need any model because you just
take anything represented class minimize
the volume but here if you want to use
the energy
then you need this model
to define it okay so the model of course
if it has scalar structure
uh then it's fine of course you say that
well you need some coverage condition
but recovery condition is just helping
you to
try to get existence when you try to
minimize okay so even if you assume
coverage condition is still the trouble
so
in a way
you are
getting some hot
conjecture type problem
but
not
using the condition of the type of the
chromology class
instead you are using the other
direction you are using some cycles
okay so what are the conditional cycles
in this case the conditional cycle is
it is topologically representable by
something compact kayla
yeah
and then you say well
what happens to the various types okay
so one time i try to get this sort of a
dual version which is easier then you
ask what the pq type
for this okay
the picot type for this actually is
the case of uh
koshi riemann manifold structure
at that time i tried to do it i couldn't
do it and before i came here prepared i
still couldn't do it
but so i i tell you what this thing is
okay
so
the analog of this type for example if
you have a class and it's represented by
a cr manifold so this is usually called
cr manifold
okay
with some
m complex directions
and let's say are real directions
this means that
let's call this x okay
so the tangent space of
x
emits a part that is invariant in the j
the part that's immediately j has come
back dimension m
and then the rest is r dimensional okay
and so this is cr manifold
and then um
if you look at the pq type
yeah at each point let's say smooth
everything you know just like kayla okay
and you also assume that it has some
cable structure as well
yeah okay
and now you have pq let's say you have
pq class
and on the member android phone now okay
so so this one is the definition of cosy
remind okay so you take the mba manifold
m for example and then you have a class
you have a cycle let's say it has it can
be represented by this for example
and then you look at the
pq class here of course
when you evaluate here
if p minus q
is bigger than r then it would be zero
because there's no enough base for it so
in this case uh you're sort of having
some filtration yeah okay then the
question is
can you
reproduce it at first i thought it would
be trivial you know with the simple
things
uh to modify it but in fact it's not
okay so when you take a cr manifold
uh you want to get um some
holomori functions on it while
holomorphin in the sense that it's cr
function
then some
strict
positivity required
yeah
so even if you assume the right kind of
positivity i still cannot do it and then
you say what what is the difficulty okay
suppose you even assume forms
okay you try to say that if you have a
cycle that has a representation
then there is a cr map into it
just like the case of holomorphic map
okay or conjugate acr whatever yeah
uh so that means that you look at the
cycles okay with a certain
well this idea of type then it could be
represented yeah of course it's a long
way from this it's actually very
different but even this is not that
simple the reason is that
suppose look at the case of of a sphere
let's say of a unisphere
2n minus 1 inside cn okay given by r
equal to 1 r is the distance to the
origin okay
then
you take a dr
and you take
j of that okay so actually usually
denoted by cr
so this one here is a kernel
okay
okay this is on this thing here okay the
kernel here gives you the complex
direction of course yeah
and
so what happens is that
you can of course take the tailor from
here pull it back okay then on the
holomorphic part
then it's like a california okay
but
when you want to do this kind of thing
then you have to watch this guy here
besides the caterpillar to a certain
power
save from power you got to watch this
part so certain power let's say the q or
something
but then um
let's uh say something about the
holomorphic situation the harmonic
situation
the proof actually goes as follows
uh over there
you take uh d bar of f
let's say alpha you write your d bar of
beta
h alpha beta bar which the taylor form
a number of times
let's say q times
to get the top degree
after you take the d bar
and then you integrate this okay that is
the um
technique of integration by parts
okay the main point is that this is a
negative situation
and the ritchie doesn't enter from the
domain
the dual one the reach he enters so if
you try something like this what happens
is that you have to put this thing in
this thing is not closed
so if you assume also that it's closed
then of course it's triviality on the
other hand
this is the kind that is not interesting
the interesting kind actually is the one
that is
strongly pseudo convex and so forth
so then
one
tries to handle this
and
try to say that um
uh
you are able to uh produce a cr map
the question is still open i'll get back
to this when i have time okay so this is
still one of the open questions another
dream there yeah can you say that open
question just a little more precisely so
you have sort of a large conjecture
right yeah but this is a psycho version
yeah sure but what approximately is the
open question the urban question is that
um
suppose your
manifold has the correct negative
curvature actually is a
negative well complexified section of
curvature
and then there's a class that can be
represented by smooth
something like this
yeah and you may need some strong pseudo
convexity and so forth if you have the
flat case then it's just the usual thing
already works if transversal uh the
invariant measure
in the normal direction and so forth
then just the whole point works the same
way
yeah
but if you have the strong slow
convexity then the question is whether
in that class
homotopic clause you can represent it by
cr map
crm means it's holomorphic along these
holomori directions the same way
yeah
yes
means that
means the following means that if you
take the
complex foliation
then you have the transversal invariant
measure so you could just
stick in
the form
in a normal direction
i think in literature there are uh
papers
those camber temper
and uh
i think about uh romanian foliation and
so forth so they look for harmonic
situation that would be analogous but
then um
it would be a straightforward
generalization of that okay so another
way
that i was uh dreaming about uh
in those days
uh
when i was here that uh
i
was trying to get rid of the model so
the trouble of course is the model the
class okay the class model
and um so suppose you are able to
represent it by something holomorphic
let's say v
holomorphic already okay inside your
ambient manifold m
okay of course you really don't know
what the model is until you get to it
however
you can always say the dimension complex
dimension
is p you can always get
a
a branch cover over it
let's finite one map okay branch cover
over pq if you see a holomorphic
then you say let's use this as a model
then because if you can solve it then
you can always get this thing a model
okay
but then the trouble is that it would be
a multi-value map from here to here
let's say this lambda sheets
then you have get
p here
to the symmetric power
of this guy
then the trouble is with the
singularities
okay
in a way that's more related to kurt's
tall now
they're this singularity okay
so um
later i saw the paper of
gomov and rickshawn
about the harmonic map to new singular
metric space given by black his
buildings
so buhari's building
so one simple example would be like this
that they were trying to explain okay
so it's more related to this kong
manifold idea that cut was talking about
earlier
then so he called they called this y
okay this is just three things okay and
then you have the two-dimensional
thing here and you want to understand
what harmonic means here okay so the way
they did it is that they construct a y
prime to explain it
so that uh by opening this up
it makes it becomes a
a half plane okay
and then use the map into this and then
the half plane here will go from here
projecting down
okay
so um there they use the notion of
harmonic map
into a singular metric space
and so
i tried a bit on this
it's not the same
so the question remains whether you are
able
uh to do this if you have a class that
could represent it as a topological
branch cover over it when you vary to
map and map into it
okay
so this uh
moves you closer
to the original
horse conjecture situation
because you are not trying to minimize
the volume and of course the question
still how do you use pt type how the pv
type fits into this picture that's not
clear either
now i want to
move on to another development
in paler geometry
that
stemmed from dan's work and also
magulo's work
is the notion of super agility
so sewer agility
deals with something slightly different
the idea is that you have m into n
again
n has uh non-positive complexified
sectional curvature
okay but you assume that m
is uh
locally symmetric let's say
and the rank
so for example the quotient of
irreducible
uh
this one here
semi
negative semi-positive semi
this is right okay okay
non-compact type yeah so so here is uh
uh the same kind of thing
locally symmetric and non-compact type
even at least two let's say the
universal cover is reduced and so forth
and then
again you want to consider the map
harmonic and here you want to say that
it's totally geodesic isometric
embedding okay so the
uh
the idea there
is that again you can take
the harmonic representative in
homotropic class
and here
you want to
get
instead of
what we had earlier when we had this
thing here
you would get the perfect square plus
the curvature term the perfect square
actually it looks like
nebra
d bob f
together with the curvature
term which i expect
so
if you know what this thing is you could
always uh
expand out and get the formula so the
main point is
what perfect squares you want to use
and in the case of
codata's vanishing theorem
when you have a uh let's say
zero p form
omega okay
then the the positive vanishing
what is being used is
this thing square
and negative
is this thing squared so this one here
the same type is here this one is
different type
okay
so
when you take a
strong rigidity or super rigidity
the whole problem is
how to interpret the square
the perfect square
so in the master kind of strong
rigidity this is being used
of course omega is the d bar of f okay
so in uh maguri's super rigidity what is
being used is this thing
square so this thing has two indices
let's say alpha
and uh
maybe maybe j k
of f alpha
yeah
and of course it's clear what to
be done for this one here is h alpha
beta
bar for example even if you're real
manifold you can always complexify it
okay
so the question is what to do of these
there are actually to be four inches
jk let's say the lm or something
so what is being done here
in this situation
is simply use uh the g
jk bar or gm
l bar
actually it's being raised
to contract
okay so that's being used there
and you could use uh
other four tenses to do it actually it's
uh this
idea of calabi
uh for this kind of agility that you use
curvature type tensors
what in my curvature type tensors you
could use for example the curvature from
here
and then you can use the standard
curvature
what is the standard curvature for
example
the standard curvature
for constant sectional curvature is
xk
maybe
xj
dx
k here j
e s k summation
okay jk
yeah
that's just constant sectional curvature
or you can
use a
constant
holomorphic sectional curvature
which would be like dz alpha
dz beta bar and then tensor you know the
same thing summation
okay
and
so
what happens is that you could use
a certain linear combination of the
curvature here together with
the
tensor from the constant
sectional or constant
holomorphic or even constant quatinionic
curvature
and you put this in
into here
and during my parts that's why you get
all this super rigidity
known from this statement so this was
published in the paper i wrote up with
my student mark and also his students
here
quite a while ago
so this is
the super rigidity
another thing i actually what i want to
talk about
uh is the case of positive curvature
they get sort of
hinted at this
so um so what happens to the positive
curvature
so if you take positive curvature
you have two troubles
first trouble is
existence of
harmonic maps
because you don't have a way of
controlling it it doesn't have as scary
as that
so how do you handle it
well
it was first handled by sax woolenberg
wooden back
so if you have
already some l2 further to l2 you're
minimizing so you have this sober left
thing you know it's good okay but you
want something more the trouble you
don't have something more okay
and um so it may happen
that you have the bubbling situation
that means
you have the you want to get the higher
orders overlap and it's concentrated
somewhere okay so you have the bubbling
so uh sox and ulenberg
uh
show that uh if you want to get the
minimizing the energy
and if manifold
then you may end up
with this thing represented by not one
but
a finite sum because the bubbling
now this bubbling process
actually is analogous
to maurice um construction of rational
curve for final manifold
so uh
actually in mori's case he forced it to
decompose by fixing two points and
deform when you go around once and they
force it to
to give you another one and so this is
the bubbling process
and actually i wrote a paper with yao at
one point to solve the frankfurt
conjectures alternative way of doing it
alternative to
more is
to show that when you have positive
tangent bundle in the graphics sense
then it must be projective space
and there you use the bubbling process
but use second variational energy to
make sure that
you could represent the fundamental
cause
of the the h2
by
a holomorphic map so this is the first
difficulty
and
one problem
which uh is still outstanding
is to show that uh when you have a final
manifold
that means that the
the canonical line bundle is negative is
compact
complex okay
and in that case uh there should be
rational curves inside
so messenger curve means holomorphic map
from
p1 into it and more we prove it by using
characteristic p
and the challenge still remains how to
do it
analytically
you try to do analytically
you have this trouble bubbling but the
bubbling actually is
how mori used to do it okay so then you
say
how are you going to handle this okay
you handle this
uh actually
to use the bubbling and then you pull
back
the tangent bundle
and it would be something harmonic that
means you pull it back
and now you take uh df
okay df is this valued
one zero form
and this is actually holomorphic
you pull it back because this is
harmonic
so then you get a uh
a holomorphic
vector bundle on this thing
after you tensor
with the canonical bundle here
and then you can decompose okay the
trouble is that the composition one is
be positive curvature want to be
negative curvature and so forth
and then
the idea
uh i i couldn't quite do it but the idea
probably is workable that um
you have some directions that are
positive and you move okay you have
another direction that is negative then
you move its complex conjugate structure
and you move it
so that somehow they come together like
this
and then you sort of cut off
like this to minimize further
to make sure that indeed you get a
holomorphic curve from p1 but
i couldn't quite do this so this is this
is the first difficulty
so what happens to the second difficulty
the second difficulty
is the curvature term
because the curvature is the wrong sign
how do you handle it
the current term is a wrong sign simply
means that
you have some eigen space for example
you have some eigen space for zero eigen
eigenvalue okay
that's the trouble okay so you may have
some eigen space that's not good if you
are able to kill those
okay then
you're okay
the question is how to kill
the bad eigen spaces
in complex geometry there are two known
ways of doing it
one way is to use symmetry
that was started by moser
when he was trying to
solve the nirnberg problem uh by the
using
some version of trigger inequality so
the iron problem is the following is
that you take s2
you assign a curvature function
k
and it has to satisfy gauss bonnet of
course
and then after it satisfy gauss.net then
you want to say that you are able to
find a metric
assuming that okay so you want to um
to solve it what happens
is that you get the standard metric
let's say d
maybe call it g
gs that's two okay
and then you can formally change it
maybe to a certain conformal change
okay with a conformal vector
okay maybe e
2 2 u or minus 2 you can remember
precisely
then what happens you get an equation
like this one plus laplacian u
uh for this thing e
uh
k e
minus two u or something yeah okay the
gauss foundation comes from this guy
yeah
and uh you have trouble solving it when
you do integrate bypass and so forth
it's precisely because you have this
bad eigen space okay
so
moses way of killing it is to assume
antipodal symmetry
so you assume because this kind of thing
is like sober left inequality actually
turing inequality you have a constant so
if you have integral symmetry you cut
the sphere into half okay and then the
constant is correct so you try to handle
this by symmetry
another way to handle it
the second way
uh is
to make things vanish at certain points
vanishing somewhere
this idea is like segal's idea of using
schwarzlammer
if you have
a
chromology class represented by
something harmonic or even represented
by co-cycles you assume vanishing at
certain points sufficiently high order
then you force the thing to vanish
yeah so um so then one tried to do this
okay and this actually
there's a big theory to it it's called
multiple ideal shift theory
another idea shift is that you want to
solve the d by equation because
of the obstruction you cannot do it but
you assume that your original thing
vanished already somewhere some good
place
okay that belongs to what is called
multiple ideal shift then automatically
you can do it okay
this actually is also related to the
bumping technique of growth
okay let's go back to the cr case
the thing that we had before okay the cr
case actually should be related to the
vanishing theorem
because
when you do the strong rigidity
okay what is being used is called
dialysis vanishing theorem for negative
line bundle yeah so suppose you have the
curvature
and you have cr manifold you don't have
the vanishing theorem for cr manifold
because uh
even if you have something strongly
pseudo convex
and
you have a class here
uh suppose the strongly through convex
cr manifold
is part of something holomorphic
but the cost here may not be extendable
to the whole class there's some
obstruction in the center
okay so in general you have trouble
and
one wants to say that
you are able to
solve the d by equation
and get
some holomorphic section or hormonal
function well it has this idea of
bumping so you take
some
complex hypersurface and then bump this
and say that the chromology there is the
same
and then that enables you to produce
something holomorphic
we got
less of what happens here
and the thing involves this vanishing
here
that's related um
okay so there are two ways of doing it
let me explore a little bit this uh
symmetry situation
okay symmetry
then of course
if you are given a manifold then the
question is
how much symmetry do you need
i mean in the case of s2 you have
antibiotic symmetry in general how much
symmetry
let's be generous and make it even
globally symmetric space well this is
that of course it's very nice okay
so then it becomes the question of
of strong agility for such bases
the question is
strong agility
for compact
symmetric hermitian symmetric
manifold
what happens now in general this is hard
even uh the case of p3 for example
okay and it's related to the
non-existence of a
complex function on s6 you blow a point
then these two things are related okay
and in general you don't know how to
handle this
so
and also there's this first difficulty
so a very
weak version of this
is the situation of global
non-deformability
when you look at strong agility of
course there's a version of just local
rigidity of rigidity
and if you have compact commission
symmetric manifold you know that is
rigid
and
strong virginity is so much harder
because of all the difficulties involved
and mainly the first one so the
weaker one is global non-deformability
so if you assume that
you have a holomorphic
family
over the disk
so that
phi invert t is x t for example this is
by holomorphic to let's say pn
for t not equal to zero
uh supposed holomorphic family then the
question is uh what happens
to this guy here
okay
that actually uh
bypasses this thing
because you know what happens
how to relate uh the neighboring one to
the
to the limit one okay
so this actually solved
in the case of pn
and
my student
jung huang
solve it for hyperquadric but for the
other spaces it is still not possible
and um so this is the compact version of
it and then you say
how how was this proved in the case of
pn
in the case of pn
actually
it is proved
by
using vector fields
so you take all the vector fields
so points all the vectors will be
something like this
in our final coordinates okay so
you take the euler vector fields
on x t
and you could actually extend them
all the way to x zero
why can you extend them you can extend
them metamorphically no trouble with
that and then you multiply by an
appropriate power of t becomes
holomorphic
the trouble with this kind of extension
is that the semi simplicity is no longer
there because you want to the vector
field will be given by the semi-simple
group actually simple group here and
when you
get the limit of vector fields by
multiplying by power of t
then when you take the lead bracket
okay
uh then when you multiply by t because
this is a quadratic
okay this thing actually becomes zero
you multiply by different powers of t
so it becomes
uh some a billion
uh
subgroup inside
yeah and uh to make sure that it doesn't
uh happen
uh you have to do some counting
by the churn classes and so forth to do
it so in general
it is not
still not possible
how to handle it and then you say
what happens to the case of higher rank
in the case of hyper quadratic you can
still do it the reason why pn is easy
is that when you count
um
the vector fields always vanish this
kind on a harder surface namely the
infinity hyperplane
but in general higher rank higher rank
this doesn't happen
and in the case of higher actually there
are some
some other things that come into the
picture
let me say something about the super
rigidity
in this regard
so a moment ago
we were explaining super rigidity by
looking at m
and then going to n
and then n here has a complex curvature
let's say the e f or something e bar f
bar
that's equal to zero something like this
okay
and uh and then
you want to show that
you have
uh geodesic uh
tourism isometric embedding
this actually
is related
to the schwarz pick r4 situation
the swastika force is the situation of
this to this okay
and then the curvature dictates how the
distance
is being contracted
yeah and then it gives you a picard and
so forth in particular it tells you that
if this is more negative
you cannot get the map into it if you
if you have a complete situation yeah
okay so the compact situation map into
it yeah
so here
when you deal with this situation is not
holomorphic but if you use this kind of
thing
it is analogous to this situation
that this is non-negative and therefore
the map there must be the fat ones must
go to the fat ones
that actually is the reason why you get
super rigidity and also they're not flat
ones around they crisscross
okay
so here in this picture
you want to do the same thing if you
have
some
higher rank ones
and you get the limit you have something
criss-crossing but then the limit uh
they sort of a bubbling situation
this
situation degeneracy the same as the
bubbling you get to the limit
and that still cannot be controlled if
you can control the bubbling so for
example by assuming that
the limit one also is a calorimetric to
start out with then a bubbling can be
controlled by the volume in that case
you could do it actually this was done
by mark and wham
under this condition
so um
the uh
the strong agility or even global
non-developability for the positive case
is
so much harder somehow
because you have to control the coverage
now
i think i'll stop here
thanks
can you connect uh
these measure rigidity theorems of
marina ratner with some of these ideas
or use measure rigidity to add to these
i don't know i mean let me let me uh
maybe i can use some of the question
time to say some more what i try to say
okay so uh so this is a very good
question because there are actually two
problems that are related to this okay
one problem is the uh
this s6 okay has no complex structure
that's hard nobody could do it okay so
there is a non-compact
version of it
one common version of it is the four
b6
and uh you take a discrete sub group
isometric group and you take the compare
quotient okay and you could get one that
has almost complex structure sort of
dual situation like this okay and then
you want to say that that one cannot be
integrated okay
now how do you show that one can
integrate it
that is more related to dan's idea of
going to a boundary
so you get the uh tangent bundle
decompose into two pieces
okay because the one zero and the zero
one
yeah okay
and uh so
the main point is that the
the discrete subgroup here has more
symmetry than
uh it then can be allowed for a complex
manifold that's the key point okay so
when you get to the boundary here
go to the limit of these things get to
the boundary
um you can get some algorithm so far as
volume is concerned
but that is not enough to give her
addiction okay to give condition simply
means that there's almost there's no
almost complex structure to start out
with
and you need some some smoothness more
than measure so you have got dexterity
strongly measured
and that is precisely
uh the differential equation for
integrability comes in
so you want to say that when you have uh
integrability then you get an extra
smoothness and then you get to the limit
you get a conviction so i try a lot on
this
but i i couldn't it's just my knowledge
it's not enough to handle this aggregate
situation but this is more related to
dan's work
of getting to the boundary
and there's another question also well
maybe i shouldn't
take away your time but i have no idea
how to use ragnarz
thank you